- Okay, I'm Maurice Samuels, the director
of the Yale Program for
the Study of Antisemitism,
and it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here
to today's webinar,
part of our Benjamin and
Barbara Zucker Lecture Series.
Our speaker is well known to many of us.
Jason Stanley is the
Jacob Urowsky Professor
of Philosophy at Yale.
Before coming to Yale in 2013,
he was Distinguished Professor
in the Department of
Philosophy at Rutgers.
A philosopher of language
and epistemology,
as well as a social and
political philosopher,
he's the author of numerous books,
including "Knowledge and
Practical Interests," 2005,
"Language in Context," 2007,
"Know How," 2011,
and two more recent books
that touch on aspects
of our current political situation,
"How Propaganda Works," 2015,
and "How Fascism Works: The
Politics of Us and Them," 2018.
And this last one especially has made him
kind of a media star lately.
I should say that my
colleague Alice Kaplan
also asked me to point out that Jason,
along with Tim Snyder,
will be giving a Franke Seminar
at the Whitney Humanities Center next year
on mass incarceration in the Soviet Union
and the United States,
with sidelong looks at
Nazi Germany and China.
So please check the Whitney
Humanities Center website
for more information on that.
Finally, before we get started,
just a word on how things today will work.
Jason will talk for about 30 minutes,
and then we'll open it up for questions.
The audience is not visible or audible,
so please submit your questions
using the Q and A button
at the bottom of your screen,
and I will ask the questions.
Feel free to submit questions
whenever you want, even during the talk.
That would actually be helpful
to me if they came in early.
Please don't raise your hand
or use the chat functions,
because we won't see them.
So the title of Professor
Stanley's talk today
is "Antisemitism and White Supremacy."
Please join me in welcoming Jason Stanley.
- Thank you so much and
thank you for coming.
So I want to talk today
about something that's,
about growing antisemitism
in the United States
and the structure and how it relates
to what's going on in the world today
and our own very particular
political situation,
our own particular, in particular,
our history of white supremacy.
So let's begin with what's going on.
I'm gonna begin with the
international situation,
with one aspect of the
and then I'm gonna talk a little bit
about what we face with white
supremacy in the United States
against Black Americans.
And then I'm going to connect this
to the topic of today, antisemitism.
So as my colleague Elli Stern
has been drawing our attention
to a global move in many countries,
not yet in the United States,
of Jewish voters to right wing,
often anti-immigrant parties,
somewhat xenophobic parties,
which movement that you see in Europe,
and certainly there is, of
course, a far right in Israel.
This belies a long
history of Jewish voters,
Jewish participation, since emancipation
on being on the side of
ethnic religious minorities
that were not themselves.
But we don't have this movement in the...
It's sort of divided here.
So we have a lot of Orthodox voters
supporting far right
parties, far right movements,
but it's less of, but we still have
a majority liberal progressive
voting constituency.
Now let's turn...
So there is this move across
the world towards a kind of...
that seems like a
repudiation of a long history
of recognizing a common alliance
between Jewish fate in a country
and the fate of other minority groups.
Partly, there is a
country that is a Jewish,
that is, Israel exists now.
And so that gives a sort of,
now that there's a nationalist movement,
there's a nation that is
associated with the religion.
But whatever the explanations of that,
my topic here is the United States,
is focused on what's going
on in the United States.
So I'm gonna quickly
review some basic facts
and then I'm going to talk
about what antisemitism,
what one structure of
antisemitism looks like
that's shared between the
"Protocols of the Elders of Zion,"
and say, Henry Ford's
"The International Jew,"
and the Ku Klux Klan, and how
that links Jewish Americans
to our Black fellow citizens,
whether Jewish or not,
and what's happening.
And then I'm going to conclude
by looking at the anti...
Talking about QAnon,
talking about the kind
of growing antisemitism
that we're finding, particularly
in the Republican Party,
among certain members
of the Republican Party.
We already see it with open
George Soros vilification.
So when Viktor Orban ran a
political campaign against,
condemning George Soros,
against George Soros in Hungary,
it was clearly recognized as antisemitic.
Now, Giuliani and many other Republicans
can condemn George Soros openly
as behind every bad thing and
link him, in exactly the ways
that antisemitic conspiracy
theories link Jews
to minority groups, and no
one seems to bat an eye.
And I'm going to argue
this is an extraordinarily
dangerous development
for the safety and
security of American Jews.
Sorry, I'm trying to...
Ah, here we go.
So, so let me begin.
So what's going on,
let's just review some
history in the United States.
So when I last,
so we all know that this country is based,
it has a long history
of explicit enslavement
of its Black population.
And then we, in many
senses, were not a democracy
until the Voting Rights Act,
until Black Americans in
the South were able to vote.
And we're seeing this rise again
with voter disenfranchisement focusing
on Black majority cities.
Trump declared the voter
fraud to be focused
in Detroit, Atlanta,
Philadelphia, Milwaukee.
This was no accident.
These are either Black majority cities
or cities with large Black populations.
So he was hearkening back
to a long standing practice
in the United States that Black...
And the Black radical tradition
was always linked with fascism.
Toni Morrison in a 1995 speech
at Howard University talks of,
called "Racism and Fascism,"
points, says that...
She says "The United States..."
She doesn't say the United
States is a fascist regime.
She says that the United States has often
preferred fascist solutions
to its national problems.
And what are the fascist solutions?
She said, "Taking the minority population
and incarcerating them in large numbers."
Now, if we look at,
so these parallels
between European fascism
and say, the Jim Crow South,
have been explored in
detail by my Yale colleague,
Jim Whitman in his book
"Hitler's American Model,"
the Nuremberg laws were, of course,
modeled on our anti-miscegenation laws.
And I just recently found out,
when UMass digitalized Du Bois' archives,
that WEB Du Bois had a piece rejected
from "The Atlantic" in 1942
where he made a direct analogy
between Hitler's treatment of Jews
and the South's treatment
of Black Americans.
So the tradition of the
mainstream press repudiating
these analogies is also old.
So in 2014, with my then
colleague, Vesla Weaver,
I looked at the numbers
for mass incarceration
in the United States.
As you may know, the United
States leads the world
in the rate at which it
incarcerates its fellow citizens.
So looking at these numbers, what we found
was if you just looked at the
Black population in prison,
I think we have 38
million Black Americans,
they're incarcerated at such a high rate
that in 2014 they formed almost 10%
of the world's prison population.
Whenever I say that,
people say there must be
some misunderstanding.
There must be some misstatement.
But it's not a misstatement.
In 2014, Black Americans,
a tiny, tiny group formed almost 10%
of the world's prison population.
So when we talk about
racism and white supremacy,
this is not some kind of past problem.
It's not a problem locatable
to lack of diversity among faculty,
although it is also present
there, or in professions.
Almost 10% of the world's
prison population comes
from the population of 38
million Black Americans.
If Germany had had a substantial
population of German Jews
and was incarcerating them at rates
like we see in the United States,
the world would never stand for it.
So obviously, there is an enormous,
unresolved continuing problem of racism
in the United States.
That's multifactorial,
linked to many issues.
But the facts are the facts.
So what does this have
to do with antisemitism?
Well, I want now to move
to what may seem like a different topic.
I'm gonna sit down again,
because, as they tell me on interviews,
I sometimes look like I'm
davening when I'm standing up.
So let's go back to the structure
of the antisematic conspiracy theory,
"The Protocols of the Elders of Zion."
So "The Protocols of
the Elders of Zion says
that there's a global conspiracy
of Jews, of elite Jews
who are seeking to advance
social justice movements
to break apart nations.
In the words of...
And "Protocols" says that movements
for universal social justice,
universal rights, rights
for minority groups,
rights for women always have this global,
this unholy alliance of capitalist Jews
and communist Jews behind them.
So the idea is that the central idea
of "The Protocols of the Elders
of Zion" is that liberalism,
moves for social justice
for minority groups,
religious, gender equality, gay rights,
that these always have behind
them this conspiracy of Jews.
And the goal is to
destroy the nation states
and replace it with world government.
Now, if you look at the
ideology of the Second Klan
in the 1920s in the United States,
you will find a remarkably similar story.
This has been explored in
Nancy MacLean's 1994 book.
She has a chapter on the overlaps
between the ideology of
the Klan in the 1920s
and the growing Nazi ideology.
Sarah Churchwell has also
explored this in her work
on interwar fascism in the United States.
Indeed, many newspapers,
as Sarah Churchwell notes, thought of...
The Italian fascists were described
as a kind of Italian Ku Klux Klan.
So Klan ideology had it
that Jews were behind
movements for Black equality
and were behind the labor movement.
And the labor movement was a
method of destroying capitalism
and forcing Black Americans
and white Americans
to work side by side as
brothers and sisters.
And the idea was that Jews were
bringing, were trying to...
And the basic thought is Jews are trying
to foment racial division
so they could take over.
So the Klan ideology is very similar
to "The Protocols of the Elders of Zion."
And you find, and it's
no surprise, of course,
that Henry Ford distributed
"The International Jew,"
hundreds of thousands of copies,
which has a similar ideology.
Now, what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna show you a video
that was...
I'm gonna show you stills from a video
that was shown right after
Rudy Giuliani's speech
at the January 6th rally,
Stop the Steal rally
in Washington, DC.
And now that you have this understanding
that Jews, the global
Jews, the global elite,
are there trying to...
And their goal is to
undermine white Christianity
by creating racial divisions
and undermining society
so they can take over.
I want you to think about that
as we look at some of these stills.
So this was directly
after Giuliani's speech,
and soon before Trump's speech
that culminated the rally,
when people marched to the US Capitol.
And I spend a lot of time
on far right websites.
There is a division between the far right
about what to think about Jews.
There's one group that's
like separate but equal,
Israel is fine, you know,
but another group says,
"No, they're always bad."
But this is the kind of thing you see,
and it's becoming increasingly mainstream.
So I'm going to share my screen now.
So here's how the video begins.
So this was shown
officially at this rally,
right after Giuliani's
speech, that Trump speaks at.
And then right after this,
they go over to the Capitol
to engage in the the events
that we're now seeing discussed
in the impeachment trial.
So this is the beginning of the video.
This is the first still.
Then they show the Capitol
building, the target.
Then they move to a,
just to a Hollywood sign.
Now, in chapter two of "Mein Kampf",
and I'm not making an analogy
between Trump and Hitler,
I think such analogies are foolish.
I am saying that there's
a similar rhetoric
and propaganda happening.
So Hitler, in chapter two of "Mein Kampf",
which is about his study
and struggles in Vienna,
he says that his first...
He claims his first quote,
unquote, supposed realization
that Jews were sort of
nefariously in charge of things
was his supposed realization
that they controlled the theater and arts.
So this is a long, you know,
when you hear Hollywood
is controlled by Jews,
some aspect of that is very longstanding
in antisemitic thought
and antisemitic ideology
and conspiracy theories.
Also that the media is controlled
by the leftist global elite.
Note that when you think about that claim,
that the media is controlled
by the leftist global elite,
think about the fact that Fox News
has long been the number one station,
that Sinclair Broadcasting,
which is a far right station,
controls more local
television networks than,
I believe, anyone else, any
other media conglomerate.
So it's as Jeffrey Herf
has documented in detail
in the case of Nazi Germany,
that claim is completely, with the Jews,
the claim is completely
false that the left controls,
much less Jewish left or Jewish right.
So here we we see a Hollywood sign.
So this is really an official rally.
It begins with Hollywood.
Then we look at the UN General Assembly.
I thank Just Security for helping me
to still these frames, the website,
Justin Hendrix helped me.
So this is the UN General Assembly.
So the idea of a global
cabal, world government,
which according to "The
International Jew,"
according to the Ku Klux Klan,
according to "The Protocols
of the Elders of Zion"
is controlled by Jews.
Now we see the European
Union parliament floor.
So another global institution
that destroys the
individuality of nations.
Trump, and then we see,
"For too long, a small group
in our nation's capital
has reaped the rewards of government
while the people have borne the costs."
So this idea of a small group
in our nation's capital.
Now, one thing Hitler
says in "Mein Kampf,"
is he notes, he says the second thing
after the entertainment
industry that he noticed,
he noticed that there
were prominent members
of the Austrian Social
Democratic Party who were Jews.
And these seemed to be prominent members
who had sort of a controlling role.
So he notes first, Jewish control
of the entertainment industry,
and secondly, he notes
prominent Jewish members
of the Austrian Social Democratic Party.
The next still is Biden, President Biden,
with a vacant stare in his eyes.
And then we shift to Chuck Schumer,
Senator Chuck Schumer
wearing a kente cloth.
Now what's going on
with Senator Chuck Schumer
wearing a kente cloth?
Well, remember, recall that according
to Ku Klux Klan ideology,
Jews foment racial division
so they can ultimately take over.
Why choose specifically Chuck
Schumer with a kente cloth?
So we have Joe Biden being,
so he's not in control.
Then we see Chuck Schumer,
and he's wearing a kente cloth
because this is a reference to the aspect
of this antisemitic ideology,
that Jews are fomenting racial division.
So part of this ideology,
you repeatedly have the Ku Klux,
even members of the Ku Klux Klan saying,
"Black people are okay as long
as they're in their place,
the good Black people."
The ideas is, Jews are stirring them up.
So then we see Nancy Pelosi
flanked by Adam Schiff
and Jerry Nadler, two
Jewish congresspersons.
And this seems to suggest
that she's controlled
by those congresspeople.
So the idea here is that
prominent Jewish members
of the Democratic Party have
a kind of controlling role.
A number of people have said to me that,
"Oh, why think this was so carefully done?
Maybe this was just so slapped together."
It's far too deliberate
to be slapped together.
So one thing you see in the video is,
let me note just a couple.
You see under Trump,
like this is the scenes of
the glorious Trump years,
they're all scenes of his rallies.
You see racial unity.
So racial unity under Trump.
So Trump brings racial
unity, Schumer divides.
We're gonna see more Black
Lives Matter protests,
so this is the kind of imagery from...
That's Trump behind....
So I want to show you
later, so if you look at,
if you think that this
is not carefully done,
so this is a part in the video.
You have these glorious Trump years.
Look at this,
this is Trump just with
everyone else faded out but him.
Then you have these glorious Trump years.
If you think this is not carefully done,
then the suggestion that
COVID is a Democratic plot,
if you look at this subway station,
the subway station is called Clinton.
So this is very carefully put together.
So I'm gonna show one
last scene from this.
So here we have the
supposed racial division,
Black Lives Matter.
And then let me show you something else,
another sign of racial unity.
Here is like the end, it ends with,
this is what happens if Trump is restored.
We have a Black man
and a white man unified
under Jesus saves, under
Christian nationalism,
which is increasingly an ideology that,
a growing ideology in the
United States that is a threat
to me and all of us who
are Jewish Americans,
and the idea that America
is first and foremost
a Christian nation.
You know, obviously, there's
strong support for...
Not obviously, but there's
strong support for Israel
in very evangelical circles that believe
that America is a Christian nation.
Think of it as separate but equal.
You know, and we know separate but equal,
that is not, for we American Jews,
that's not something that
we should really promote.
So I speak a lot of the time,
because I work on on the far right,
I've spent a lot of time,
especially in recent months,
talking about Black Trump supporters,
Black members of the Proud Boys.
And I was recently told by
a researcher working on this
that the key to...
There's a high bar for Black
members of the Proud Boys
or these far right organizations.
But they really have to be
very Christian and anti-Jewish.
So there is a route to this
white supremacist structure
that we are seeing,
this white supremacist
structure that we are seeing
has a route to include nonwhites,
but it's via Christianity.
So what I think we're seeing is,
we're seeing a rise...
We're seeing a rise on everything
but level of antisemitism
in the United States.
It's not possible to
decouple the idea of...
Well, let me just say
that in the United States,
there's a longstanding desire
of any group that is not Black
to align themselves with whiteness.
And many American Jews
are, of course, white.
Some are Black, but many of us are white.
And there's a desire
to be on the other side
of this traditional division,
this racial hierarchy
in the United States.
But I think what we can see
in this growing antisemitism
that gets associated with,
that happens when you have
these regular protests
against the massive racial
injustice in the country,
that it comes around to Jewish people,
to direct at Jewish people.
There's no escaping that.
There's an understandable desire not
to be in the target of this,
but the structure of antisemitism,
the structure of 20th century
antisemitic conspiracy
theories, as opposed, say,
to blood libel is that Jewish people
are behind movements for equality.
Jewish people are behind racial division.
What that means is that
unless we deal with the fundamental causes
of racial division, the
massive economic inequality,
the incredible problems
in our carceral system,
in our prison system,
there's always going to be,
as my colleague, Elizabeth
Hinton is arguing
in a forthcoming book, essentially,
revolutions against
militarized police forces
that essentially seek to
cement and protect a hierarchy
of racial wealth.
And those revolutions,
uprisings against that,
will be represented as the kind of,
as we've seen, as sort of
threats to law and order,
cities out of control,
and given how deeply embedded
the antisemitic narratives are,
Jewish people are going
to be implicated in that.
And so this is a pragmatic argument
to be involved in struggles
for racial justice.
There's clearly an
ethical and a political...
There's clearly an ethical demand
that I believe is part
of my heritage here.
But the idea that you could
disassociate these things
seems, as a scholar of propaganda
who studies how narratives embed
and are familiar to people,
they, you know, you can't
just get rid of a narrative.
And this is what we're seeing with QAnon.
Narratives, stories, they
live in people's minds.
They seem familiar.
When they hear there's
a global plot of elites,
you can say, okay, this time,
the Jews aren't involved this time.
It's another global plot of elites.
But that is an antisemitic
conspiracy theory.
The idea that you can just
take out the original target
of the conspiracy theory is ludicrous.
I mean, it's implausible, let's say.
There's an understandable
desire to do that.
But we are, sorry, I'm saying we.
I'm Jewish, but American Jews,
I think what we're seeing...
The global, this use of antisemitism
along with white,
essentially, white supremacy
as sort of responses to
racial justice movements,
is, I think, inevitable
given the structure
of antisemitic conspiracy
theories in the 20th century
which link Jews to movements for equality.
And now, so yeah.
And I think I'll end
there and take questions.
- Okay, thank you, Jason.
There are a lot of questions
and I encourage people
to keep submitting them, as we asked.
So start with a factual question here.
So there are a few people want
to hear more about that video.
So where, who made it,
where exactly was it shown,
was it only shown at the January 6 rally,
tell us, give us a little
bit more background.
- It's been shown at multiple
Stop the Steal rallies.
I hate even saying the
expression stop the steal,
because linguistically
stop the steal presupposes
that the election was stolen.
And the election was not
stolen, as I have to say.
And so when you say Stop the Steal rally,
you are actually reinforcing
the propagandistic frame.
But it was shown at the December
12th Stop the Steal rally.
It was showed at an Atlanta
Stop the Steal rally.
It was shown at multiple
Stop the Steal rallies,
and it's of different lengths.
- And who made it?
Do you know who? No one's taking...
- It's something called the
Right Side Broadcasting Network.
They seem to have a large
following on Twitter,
but they're very mysterious.
And multiple news organizations
have been trying to figure
out who is implicated.
- Mm-hmm, I mean, this--
- Yeah, I would argue...
I mean, the idea that it's
not antisemitic is ludicrous.
- No, no.
And also, I would say that it's not
a unique example of this.
- That's right.
- I mean, we saw this going
back to the 2016 election
where there was all kinds of imagery
that would juxtapose Hillary
with a Jewish star behind her--
- Trump tweeted an image of Hillary
with a Jewish star behind
her on a pile of money.
- Yeah, exactly.
Or things that would single
out Soros, Blankfein--
- The closing ad for Trump was antisemite,
not as explicit as this,
but it showed Soros,
Blankfein, and Janet Yellen,
who's Jewish.
- Right, right.
- It was all about elites,
money, so this is...
And of course, Trump has
several times called,
in front of Jewish American audiences,
said that "Netanyahu is your
prime minister," which is...
- So a question about
something you alluded to,
which is this split on the right,
that you have who are
just pure haters of Jews,
and then you have some who
make an exception for Israel,
which I think you, you know,
describe as separate but equal,
but this idea, it's basically this idea
that they in fact have a
lot to admire about Israel,
and especially they admire
those aspects of Israel
that people, Jews on the
left, have a hard time with,
which is the ethnonationalist elements.
But this idea that, so are you saying,
that what they like about
it is like, okay, fine.
There's this state for Jews,
and Jews should go there.
Is that their idea,
that they think that Jews don't
actually belong in America?
- So there's multiple views.
So Brenton Tarrant,
the New Zealand mosque
killer, mass murderer, said,
you know, "Jews are fine as
long as they're in Israel."
So that's one view on the extreme right.
The ethnonationalism, unfortunately,
and this is really problematic,
has been a model for...
So I was giving a lecture in Berlin,
and I went to a rally for the AfD,
which was antisemitic.
And the vast majority of...
And I met with the German
minister of antisemitism,
they have a special minister.
And he confirmed this.
The vast majority of antisemitic incidents
in Germany are done by the right wing.
So, but at this AfD rally,
Alternative for Deutschland,
the far right German party,
that one of whose main things is
to roll back Holocaust education,
all the discussion we're having here
about 1619 Project,
they're having in Germany
about Holocaust education.
So AfD runs on taking down
the monuments in Berlin,
Hocke argued that one should
take down the monuments,
Peter Eisenman's monument to
the murdered Jews of Europe.
They're running on changing
Holocaust education
in the schools like, why should
we be ashamed of our past?
Et cetera, et cetera,
same exact thing as here.
And they fly, at the AfD rally,
there were many, many
Israeli flags being flown.
So Israel is being touted as an example,
rather than a secular liberal democracy
with Jewish holidays
and with Jewish history,
it's being touted as an
example of ethnonationalism.
And of course, there are
prominent far right leaders
who are linked to Netanyahu.
- So what about, someone asked
and I can't not ask you to comment
on the Jewish space lasers,
the Marjorie Taylor Greene.
Where did that come from?
What? How do we--
- So there's a couple...
So QAnon has now,
there's a great Just Security article,
there's a terrific piece by Talia Lavin,
in, I think it's in "The New Republic."
I strongly recommend Talia Lavin's piece.
David Livingstone Smith,
the brilliant philosopher
who works on dehumanization,
he has a terrific piece
in the foreword on QAnon,
all explaining QAnon well,
as the mother of all
antisemitic conspiracy theories.
It marries "The Protocols
of the Elders of Zion"
with blood libel.
So of course, as we know,
there's multiple forms of
antisemitism in Eastern Europe,
Western, "The Protocols
of the Elders of Zion,"
it originates in Russia, in
St. Petersburg, of course,
but it's really, to
me, is associated with,
it's sort of a 20th
century Western European
antisemitic conspiracy theory.
And in Eastern Europe and
motivates the pogroms,
I don't have to tell you,
Maury, is blood libel,
that Jews have these satanic rituals.
QAnon marries "Protocols
of the Elders of Zion"
and blood libel.
It marries the two most
vicious antisemitic
conspiracy theories, which are different.
"The Protocols of the Elders of Zion"
does not talk about satanic rituals.
So it's remarkable to see
a global cabal of elites
who have satanic rituals
and are trying to bring
about world communism
via capitalism somehow.
So the Jewish space laser thing,
well she says the Rothschilds control it.
- Right. It doesn't get older than that.
I mean, that's just the heart of--
- Exactly. That's what we are facing.
And what I'm saying is like,
it is inextricably tied
to Jewish involvement in
Black protests, this idea.
And so, and you're not
going to be able to get rid,
and once there's a structure,
you're not going to be
able to get rid of it.
- Yeah, and so could you
say a little bit more
about the relationship
between Christian nationalism
and white nationalism in the US.
Are they the same?
And if you could...
Some people wondered if you
could recommend something
to read on that.
You've been so great
about citing other people
and it would be great if you could.
- Yeah, so the Perry and Whitehead book,
Samuel Perry and Andrew Whitehead's book
on American Christian nationalism,
and Philip Gorski's work,
my colleague Philip Gorski here.
They're both great.
Kathleen Belew on white
supremacism, B-E-L-E-W.
These are some recent important works
on the US context.
I think these intersect,
if you look back at...
So fascism is not, you know,
when you look at Nazism,
national socialism,
which I think is a sort of,
that is ideologically,
that is the overlap with the Ku Klux Klan.
The Ku Klux Klan
is a white supremacist
Christian nationalist movement,
but, you know, Goebbels in a 1935 speech,
"Communism with its Mask Off" says,
"The Judeo-Bolsheviks are coming for you,
and they're gonna destroy
traditional religion."
The Nazis are the
supporters of Christianity,
the defenders of traditional Christianity.
So you have this conceptual distinction
between people who are,
we're the defenders
of Christian nationalism
from Judeo-Bolsheviks,
and sort of Christian nationalism itself.
But I think, to understand the move
that the Republicans, not the Republicans,
because there are many good Republicans
who aren't involved in this at all,
but within the Republican Party,
I believe it's fair to say,
it's been allowed to fester
and it's growing.
So you have an appeal for a multiracial,
Islamophobic, antisemitic
Christian nationalist movement
that will draw some people of color.
And that will be,
I mean, I don't think we
should excessively focus
on the Proud Boys.
I was speaking to a
researcher the other day
who was working on these, on militias.
People need to understand
that militia movements
are embedded everywhere.
Like Michigan, of course,
has long had this.
But all across the South, as
government has shrunk back,
we have white militias,
extremely low information voters,
these are not the Proud Boys.
They regard the Proud Boys
as like Hollywood militias.
And Christianity, Christian nationalism,
you know, there's the Black people
in the cities are coming for us.
There's a rural urban divide.
- And are there Christian groups in the US
that are critical of that,
of the Christian ethnonationalism?
- Oh yeah.
Especially Black Christian groups, yeah.
But, I mean, Christianity is,
I mean, it's a very wide tent.
So I don't think by any means...
You had a kind of good fortune
as this is discussed
in Bradley Hart's book
on Hitler's American friends.
You had a kind of good fortune
that Father Coughlin was Catholic.
He was deeply antisemitic,
but he wasn't embraced
by all the Protestants
because he was Catholic.
So there's different...
There's a history of anti-Catholicism
in the United States
among these movements.
But I think actually that's ending,
and we're finding a far right
Christian nationalist,
integralist, quasi-fascist movement
among the Catholics in the United States.
- And what about,
so there are a couple of
questions about people saying,
where do you see the greater
threat to Jews in America,
especially, or maybe then to the world?
Do you see it coming more
from these right wing groups
that you're talking about?
Or what about, you know,
is Islamist antisemitism,
or you know, as some people say,
antisemitism on the left
and on college campuses
and things like that?
How do you parse it?
- Well, I don't think...
I think that there's
fundamentalist religions
and Islam has fundamentalism.
Judaism has fundamentalism.
Christianity has fundamentalism.
Those are all from the right.
Islamic fundamentalism is a right wing,
and there's no such thing as a left wing,
anti-feminism, anti-gay.
I mean, there's anti-colonial movements,
there's people who are,
but I don't think there's...
When people say Louis
Farrakhan is left wing,
I have to laugh.
I mean, Louis Farrakhan is a homophobic,
anti-feminist, Trump supporting
right wing ultra-nationalist.
Now he happens to be an
ultra nationalist for...
So in my book, I discuss Black nationalism
and the version of Zionism that,
not my version, that is
ethnonationalist in character.
Those originate as movements
that are minority nationalist movements,
but Fanon is very good
on this, on violence.
He says, "If a minority
nationalist movement can start
as an anti-colonialist movement,
but once it takes over
the country and wins,
it has to stop that.
It has to become more inclusive."
It has to become...
So Fanon really well describes it.
But you have these, Black nationalism,
there are extremely
patriarchal, conservative
right wing elements there, Islamophobia.
So I think, I mean, Islamic...
There's obviously fundamentalist
groups in every religion,
and Islam is no exception to that.
So I think fundamentalism,
and again Elli Stern is a great scholar
and has done great work
here on exploring the ways
in which Orthodox Jews have
engaged in antisemitism
against liberal Jews and secular Jews.
- Yeah, so let's talk a
little bit more about that.
So there are a couple of
questions about Jewish,
right-wing Jews and
what to make of the fact
that ultra Orthodox or Haredi
Jews did support Trump.
How do you explain that?
Or do they not care about
the antisemitic elements
that you've been showing
that are at the heart of,
if not Trump himself
necessarily, but Trumpism?
How do you explain that?
- Yeah, and there's Orthodox
communities in Hungary
who support Viktor Orban.
So again, at least, I mean...
Here, I just rely on
Professor Stern's work,
who is the scholar of this
in the world right now.
He's investigating the deep history
of the orthodoxy and
its turn to the right.
So one aspect you find
in Stern's scholarship,
is first a description, Stern breaks down,
and I've seen some of the manuscript
of his forthcoming book,
breaks down the ways
in which Orthodox Judaism
in the United States
looks like fundamentalist Christianity
or fundamentalist Islam.
Private schools, they want
private schools paid for
by the government.
Guns, Israel, Herzl partly
wanted this about Israel,
to change the image of Jews
from a sort of one kind of,
you know, from me or whatever,
and you, to sort of soldiers with guns
and so that sort of gun culture exists.
It's not, you know, the
NRA is not an institution
that automatically seems anathema
if you're used to various
tropes from Israel.
And Stern talks about how
we need to pay attention
to the fact that many Jewish people
might not themselves be Orthodox,
but yet they're part of an
Orthodox community of values.
And so there are many common interests
between fundamentalist religious groups.
I mean, it was a great,
it's really a mystery to me
that the Republican Party
has not appealed to Muslim Americans,
an incredibly wealthy,
prosperous, successful group,
which does have groups, sub groups,
that that would be naturally
Republican, like Orthodox Jews.
It should be no surprise
that very religious groups
have common interests.
And what we see is that.
- Right.
And that, you know, I
think does explain some
of what took a lot of people by surprise,
which was a certain Latino vote for Trump,
which shocked people, but
conservative Catholics...
And there is actually a question about...
which is not exactly the same thing,
but about the intersection
between right wing Catholicism,
like extreme, you know,
that kind of extreme brand
that Steve Bannon and
Michael Flynn had been part,
you know, and QAnon, and this phenomenon
that you're talking about.
- I want to say one more
thing about antisemitism,
about right wing, about
antisemitism even among Jews.
I was told recently
that it's Ashkenazi Jews
who often get subject to this.
- Okay, so a question about
what to say to people who say,
"Well, Trumpism can't be fundamentally...
there can't be antisemitism
in it because look,
Trump's own grandchildren are Jewish."
Jared and Ivanka are Orthodox Jews.
How do you respond to
think about question?
- I mean, I think, again,
it helps to think about race here,
where many, I mean, I'm not talking
about what is in Trump's heart.
Trump himself says many
things that are, you know...
"Do I want Jews counting my money?"
Speaking to Jewish audiences,
talking about greed.
So, I mean, I think that the fact is
that you can be a white person married,
with a Black grandchild
and still be racist.
I'm not saying Trump is antisemitic,
but I'm saying the fact that
he has a Jewish son-in-law
who repeatedly is referred
to as the globalist member,
of the cabinet, does not mean
that he's not using antisemitic policies,
I mean, politics, engaged
in antisemitic politics.
I think there's no question
we're seeing antisemitic
politics and tactics being used.
Let's stop asking what's
in people's hearts
and start asking what they're doing,
what they're doing to retain power.
Antisemitism is always, and
will always be a powerful way
to grab power in a country.
Spreading conspiracy theories where,
my theory of antisemitism, I
lean toward a theory that says,
a young philosopher named Joshua
Stein is working this out,
that Jews are the center
of any conspiracy theory.
They're the group that it's aimed at.
And I think that that kind of,
if we think of fascism,
as I do in my work,
as a set of tactics to retain power,
we realize like, somebody
like an Israeli politician
can use those tactics.
There was a terrific article
in "The Intercept" years ago,
which is now scrubbed away,
called "How Steve Bannon made Breitbart
into a Pro-Israel Haven for Antisemites."
And the comments was all antisemites.
And it talked about how in Israel,
there was lots and lots of
antisemitic propaganda aimed
at left, Labor politicians,
very explicit antisemitic propaganda.
because who knows antisemitic propaganda
and how to use it better than
I mean, better than, you know,
I was raised being told
about it by my parents.
- Mm-hmm, okay. So there
are a lot of questions.
And I, first of all, let me apologize
because I'm not gonna be able to get
to all of these questions.
There are so many questions,
which is really a sign of
how engaged this audience is,
which is great, but there
are a lot of questions about,
they basically boil down to
what can we do about this?
What kind of practical or
even philosophical resistance
can we offer to the situation
that you're outlining here?
- I think that antisemitism,
racism, these ills, rise in,
but especially antisemitism,
rises in conditions where
people feel the government
has betrayed them, where the
government is really in control
by some elites who are benefiting.
And I think the number one thing we can do
to stem antisemitism is a massive program
to make government work
again in the face of COVID.
You will never eliminate
antisemitism as an ill,
that is, I think, tragically permanent.
But wait, we're echoing.
Do you hear an echo?
- No, no.
- So, but I think that in
moments of enormous anxiety,
economic enormous anxiety, fear,
the feeling that your government
has deeply betrayed you,
this tends to lead to an
increase in antisemitism,
blaming certain groups, with the Jews...
So if there's this, the
elite have betrayed us,
they've betrayed us,
they're funneling our money,
they're dividing us, they're betraying us.
So if we can address the
racial division in our country,
if we can address racial
injustice and tamp down the sort
of supposedly outward signs
of what the Jews are doing
by addressing racial inequality
and the horrific conditions
facing many Black Americans,
and then direct, show that
the government is working
for all Americans, rural,
urban, in the face of COVID,
then you will cut down the base.
You'll do problem dissolution.
- Mm-hmm, very interesting.
And one thing people have pointed out,
and I want to give you
the chance to say this,
that you're not saying that
all Orthodox Jews are racist
or anything like that.
- Oh, no.
- So just, and in fact
there are many branches--
- No Orthodox, absolutely not,
or involved in any sense in racism.
I'm saying they too will be,
we all, Orthodox and non-Orthodox Jews,
will be targets of a growing
white supremacist movement.
Of course, I don't think Orthodox...
What I was talking, and I'm not
even, yeah, I don't think...
I don't think when Orthodox Jews vote
for Trump they're voting...
I mean, there's a racism problem
among all white
communities, let's face it.
I mean, all white communities in America
have a racism problem.
You know, so I don't
want to exonerate either.
And it's on Orthodox and non-Orthodox.
There are plenty of people
who deny that racism,
despite vast evidence of massive
racial inequality at birth,
racial wealth gaps,
enormous racial wealth gaps,
and 10 to 20 to one,
all white communities are implicated.
But I don't see Orthodox
Jews or non-Orthodox Jews
any more implicated,
and our Black Orthodox Jews that I know.
But I don't see Orthodox
communities implicated
in racism any more than any other group
that is majority white.
But let's face it, if
you want the government
to pay for private
schools for your people,
and that's your primary interest,
you are implicated in
racism in the United States
because we need the government.
We need funds to go to
people who don't have,
who have been historically
unjustly oppressed
and subjugated.
And so if you're in any community,
be it a white Christian
community, an Islamic community,
a Hindu community, a Jewish community
that is pushing for certain policies
that are going to have
downstream negative effects,
like paying for schools
just for your own group,
rather than addressing inequalities,
you're gonna be implicated.
- Okay, and the last question,
'cause we're almost out of time,
but do you feel that the fact
that the Trump
administration is behind us,
that we're now starting
the Biden administration,
is that a cause for hope,
I mean, in the sense
that these, antisemitism
and this rhetoric might
dissipate a little bit,
or do you see it as, you know,
is the rage and Stop the Steal anger
gonna actually make it worse?
- I think that antisemitism is an ill
that is permanent in American society,
and in many societies, it lay dormant.
This is a country in which
we have been flourished
like almost no other country,
but it's like playing with fire.
And so it's out now,
it's out in very open ways
that have never been
this open in my lifetime.
And it threatens and
it's gonna be the basis,
and we have many QAnon
supporters openly in Congress,
and I've never seen anything like it.
And the conditions, that we
have like 15 months to deal
with the social basis of mistrust
that we know from history
feeds antisemitism
in far right ethnonationalist movements.
So, no, I feel it could be
the calm before the storm.
- Yeah, okay.
Well, on that note,
please join me, everyone,
in silently thanking
Professor Jason Stanley
for what was really a very
stimulating and fascinating talk.
So thank you, Jason, for doing this
and especially on such short notice
and yes, thank you.
So--
- Thank you so much.